[Music]
we've been havin trouble with piracy
September some countries have been
giving them safe haven
they'll take hostages or go for our
Rovers just like the Wild West out there
your first time in the war zone three
years over the Arctic Circle and a heck
of a lot of Army Navy games I guess
there's not much you have a cigarette
well look it's almost a full moon a
large stretch of the fosters real black
[Music]
[Music]
but we have what looks like unidentified
Rovers approaching our position possible
pirate activity
okay
we're not clear I repeat we are not
clear we have multiple enemy craft in
pursuit
[Music]
this is major Roy McBride I'm attempting
to reach dr. Clifford McBride
this is dr. McBride son
dad I'd like to see Union
I've recall how we used to what black my
movies together musicals were your
favorite
I remember you tutoring me in math you
[Music]
instilled in me a strong work ethic
you should know I've chosen a career
that you would approve of
[Music]
but dedicated my life to the exploration
of space and I thank you for that
[Music]
what is happening out is a crisis of
unknown magnitude
[Music]
we believe your father may be involved
my father's dead what exactly are you
implying for me
exploration is known as a noble venture
we have to hold out the possibility that
your father may be hiding from us
[Music]
we have a job to do are you ready I'm
ready
[Music]
[Music]